[Musique]
mathieu alors au seuil à ayem qui est la
fin toujours rejoignent ayem et matthieu
delormeau ont travaillé ensemble sur nrj
je sais que vous vous êtes un petit peu
engueulé sur nrj12 paraît quand même un
jour vous avez failli vous taper dessus
intégrez vous eu lieu mais il paraît que
vous êtes enfermé dans la loge oui ça
c'est vrai c'est à dire ayez m'énerver
faire mal aux une ayem énervé oui et
bien ayem a quelque chose à vous dire
ayem est la regarde elle est magnifique
tout l'art et rouge
elle est allée elle est magnifique
franchement alors on va voir regarder ce
qui s'est passé entre vous et là
j'aimerais que vous parliez vous allez
nous dire si vous voulez cayenne et
parle ou pas s'il ouvrait la porte à m
et si ayem concept aussi de venir sur le
plateau parce qu'elle peut dire non j'ai
pas envie de voir sa gueule voilà à ok
regardez ce qui s'est passé entre ayem
et mathieu pas cap
après toutes les horreurs qu a dit
matthieu delormeau sur toi de balancer
son numéro à l'antenne mais c'est quoi
4,07
oui quel appareil je dois te laisser on
a beaucoup d'appels tomates
c'est une galère ça c'est si ça pollue
car si ça peut lui permettre de faire
marcher son émission c des blacks de son
niveau c'est assez pathétique mais c'est
pas très grave encore une fois si ça
peut faire parler du mag
bravo michel auger décolleté un petit
peu chaud mathieu est ce que vous avez
fait d'écouter ayem voilà ah ça y est
c'est reparti mais des mecs qui sont
tendus 0,7 alors aujourd'hui c'est alors
qu'ils ont lu sur les lèvres
allawi en plus c'était de ma faute alors
mathieu ce que vous acceptez de
l'écouter oui mais bien sûr la porte de
l'amitié ce que cette porte va s'ouvrir
ou pas à m on vous écoute je sais pas
j'ai dit un petit peu
très honnêtement maintenant j'ai
quelques arguments pour le convaincre je
sais que dans la vie il adore de shell a
des arguments lui les voitures ouais
j'ai des arguments merci en ce gentil
pour l'intervention
je sais qu'il adore de choses dans la
vie les belles voitures et les belles
montres j'ai pas pu venir avec ma
voiture mais je me avec une très belle
montre donc oui j'accepte d'aller le
voir et qu'on discute mais l amont la
vente révèle assez clair c'est à dire
qu'elle me l'offre c'est bien j'ai
l'impression
oui alors oui ou non d'ailleurs une
pression oui alors mathieu est ce que
j'accepte qu'elles viennent masquer ou
payant puisque vous avez dû dire pour
quelle ville accepte bien devenir mais
non mais je n'ai évidemment absolument
rien contre ayem c'est la montre bien vu
pour être sérieuse évidemment absolument
rien contre ehiem on a travaillé
ensemble on a été ami tout ça c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a un petit peu plus en
froid elle est malheureusement quand
même très très très nerveuse donc dès
qu'on dit un truc contraire elle
s'énerve
ce que j'apprécie moins c'est qu'elle se
sert souvent de l'antenne pour régler
des comptes alors ça pourrait se faire
parfois c'est vrai qu'on lui fera ici
elle fait toujours que c'est moderne
devrait donc voilà c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est plus amie pour
autant je la respecte je lui souhaite le
meilleur et évidemment que je démens il
a aimé auriez-vous oui mais au fond
d'eux n'avaient évidemment on peut
jamais totalement d aimer les gens qu'on
a aimé voilà évidemment
donc j'aurai toujours des sentiments
très positif pour ayem maintenant c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est plus à me et
progresse et ben voila merci à liège est
ce que vous acceptez de venir ben moi
j'accepte lui dit qu'on n'est plus amie
pour mon l'était toujours parce que
quand on s'aime très fort on peut avoir
des moments difficiles mais ça n'empêche
pas qu'on sème donc pour moi il est
toujours mon ami et je laime toujours
très fort allez venez rejoindre le
plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais là dessus
[Musique]
à la fois rien
allez allez est avec nous
[Musique]
ayhan sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
qu'elle est venue j'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un de marchés autant pour arriver
sur ce plateau sur la vie de madame si
la yamaha saison matière il y avait des
petites gens on va écouter on a des
points communs alors merci
ayem merci d'être là merci brial la
merci à rachid badouri on est dans le
top 5 après bon j'aurai plein de
questions à vous poser bien entendu un
match que vous avez fait laver lobbies
ou alien absolument merci c'est bien
c'est bien peu